let's bring in Juwan Howard he was
introduced as the new head coach back on
May 22nd agreeing to a five-year
contract if I would have told you 25
years ago JaJuan hey by the way you're
gonna be the head coach at Michigan one
day what would you said I wouldn't
believe you until you're crazy but did
you have designs did you when did you
start thinking about being a coach I
started back when 2009 2010 season when
I was playing for the Portland
Trailblazers
and I had a really good conversation
with Nate McMillan and Nate and I were
talking about just the future and what I
wanted to do after the game is you know
when I'm retired from the game of
basketball and so I was talking to make
about well you know maybe fun authors or
something like that and he said you know
what I can see you as coaching someday
and I said why and he was like well you
know I just recall the time when I was
playing for George Karl and George was
and I were talking and we he just saw
coaching me and he said that's the same
thing I see in you know a lot of you
know things that we've you know been
through and some of your suggestions and
always on point but more important you
always like caring and giving to your
teammates he's like I see a coaching you
so I started like thinking about that
conversation and then from there I
assigned with the Miami Heat and I
started working with coach Erik
Spoelstra and Davis's Delon Thursday I
said the same exact thing and I was like
what you know what you know maybe that
is my calling and from then on I haven't
looked back but also when that job for
it when you first hear John Beilein is
going to the Cleveland Cavaliers what's
the first thing that you do first thing
I did was my heart started pounding I
was breathing hard like wow you know
what
and I started like getting a little
sweaty I'm like wow you know I can
picture myself you know being a next
coach for the University of Michigan I
was surprised like you know a lot of
people was on Coach B line sign with the
Cleveland Cavaliers
no one heard about you know Coach
beeline being mentioned as a candidate
and then from leave in Michigan the Maha
Mamata a place that I always endure and
dreamed of someday you know coming back
and just you know working at some type
of form of fashion for the University
and and the coaching job opened up and
I'm like you know I think I see that see
I can vision myself being the next coach
submission in it from then on a few days
later I get a call from the research
firm and the people that in the
University of Michigan hired for the
coaching search and they said there was
interest so and they actually did I had
matrix I said I sure do but how did how
did LeBron and d-wade lobby for you like
well that's really broad I don't know
about lobbying I don't know if that's a
correct word but I would say this they
felt that you know because that job had
opened up that you know they thought
that I should be a strong candidate or
it's not a strong candidate should be
the head next head coach and I guess you
can call it Lobby
[Laughter]
yeah I guess it is Lobby but that I felt
really you know special that I have a
you know a guys who you've been in the
wars with been in the trenches whether
you won in two titles with or lost two
and our NBA titles but we've been in a
room together we've been in practice
floor together we've been through some
good times bad times but the respect
level that we have for one another that
meant a lot just to hear that coming
from them too but if you have LeBron and
D Wade who are helping you get the job
or at least speaking up on your behalf
I'm guessing you already have
scholarship offers out to D Wade and
LeBron sons both are very talented a
couple great genes everybody seems to
have a Michael Jordan storage you on so
what's your Michael Jordan story my
Michael Jordan story you talk about
serving Michael was he
for me back in 1996
MJ no actually is 95 December 95 MJ had
a Space Jam movie that he was shooting
up in LA and they built the dome for him
so Tim Grover was his trainer at the
time Tim who was leaving Chicago and I
was training with tennis was going to be
my second summer training with Tim
Grover and I could I had hired his
services and so he told me so well I'm
leaving for LA for the summer to go work
with Michael and I'm like oh wow you are
I'm thinking like who I'm I'll have to
work with me you know I I need to get
better and so Tim didn't often and by
but I said you know what I'm going to LA
I picked up my bags moved to LA for the
summer and my plan was to stay in a
hotel it's something like Embassy Suites
or something that's very expensive but I
knew I would pay a lot of money yeah
uh-huh and I knew I probably didn't have
the money to pay for the hotel for an
entire summer but I was gonna give it a
try the first day I traveled to LA I got
to the gym and MJ had heard that I was
going to be there he's looking forward
to you know working me working out with
him and stuff like that and so he
offered to give me a room in his house
that he was staying at and I'm like you
know oh you know I don't want to impose
on you he's like no you know what my
wife is leaving I have plenty of room
there's extra room you could stay with
us he said you know I just appreciate
the fact that you have flew all the way
here they come work out so like you sure
sounds like you know well I better go
ahead and take this off before they
change his mind how big was the house
you guys were staying in oh wow the
houses had to be about over ten thousand
see like so we're like Mulholland Drive
oh boy yeah beautiful view but you know
that was so no nice
you know kind of for MJ to do that and
you know I would never ever forget that
I got chances and I workout with him
they're tired summer and yeah but then
he goes out and puts forty on you the
next season probably doesn't he well
he's a of course he said maybe Ben I
think it's like fifty five you know MJ
is that type of guy I mean he's uh you
know he'll give you the shirt off his
back but when it comes time when you
lights up on the court and you know he's
standing side by side and you know
occitane you better believe he's gonna
do whatever it takes to win he's John
Howard the Michigan head basketball
coach joining us what did you save from
the Fab five days what did you save from
the Fab five days did you like your
Jersey your your your shorts like do you
think you have it all no I have all five
jerseys understand five is the blue away
jerseys so someday I'm gonna Axl's guys
to sign their name on it and I'm have to
put it up either in my office or in my
house so and I disrespect the guys I'm
going to impose it on your signature but
that's right that's how I make you know
moment for me of saving those jerseys
and being able to just display it so my
family can see it well invite them all
back g1 they they are my brothers for
life
they always welcome to come here and not
only just be here to you know see a game
but they can come in practicing they can
teach the price I'll just give the
whistle to the one of them or all of
them and I'll just sit back and just
Shack some balls and rebound you know
whatever he need me to do but I I wasn't
sure if you were getting an NBA job and
there was rumors about you interviewing
for the Lakers jump did you ever get
that interview with the Lakers yes I did
yes actually I died didn't you happen I
would say about two weeks prior to the
interview with the University of
Michigan okay rookie job yeah yeah I was
curious and then it's like talking to
Patrick Ewing down through the years
that hope you know hoping that he would
get an opportunity I didn't know if it'd
be in college or in the pros and the
same with you you know you're around the
pro game for so long what's the biggest
challenge
you're gonna have at Michigan well yeah
my plan was in the beginning was to be a
NBA head coach interview four five head
coaching jobs in the NBA
- last year and three this year and so
people always asked if I ever wanted to
coach college basketball and I said well
yeah that will only be one job that I
would be interested in whenever b-line
retires and that's University of
Michigan so now that's happened the big
difference I would say from the NBA and
coach and our college is recruiting you
know now you have to go out there on the
road and and on convinced try to you
know convince a you know kids about what
are you wonderful University this is
yeah but why don't you just wear your
Fab five uniform well I think that
probably will help but took today you
know a lot of these kids don't even know
who five five years or your players old
do your players know yes they know okay
okay the documentary of the 3435 you
know I'll get a chance to give it's no
wash debt and so a lot of kids know now
hey Juwanna Congrats
good for you and wish you well at
Michigan and we appreciate your time
dan I appreciate that Jason had me and
I've always been a big fan of yours and
you know you've done an excellent job so
I'm always watching you and listening to
you and stuff like that so keep it going
my man
thank you John that's a Juwan Howard
Michigan basketball coach former heat
assistant and won two titles with the
Miami Heat
Continental Tire Coaches Corner no
matter what you do no matter how you
drive where you drive Continental has a
tire for you for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]